okay
hi uh yeah as ed i'm tim ruffles i'm
currently working on a
product called psychic.js which is a
code quality tool
for javascript and today i'm going to be
talking about
handling lots and lots of asynchronous
code
big asynchronous processes involving
lots and lots of inputs
going lots of different directions um
aka
call back hell um but i think we've got
call back hell wrong
i think all the kind of typical blog
posts you see where people start going
on about
callbacks being javascript's go to and
how you can't run anything complicated
in javascript as soon as you start using
callbacks it all turns into a big
spaghetti code mess
um i think they kind of missed the point
so in this i'm going to be
talking about how you can handle most
callback stuff with
just the tools you already know of
javascript and then we're going to be
looking at what i think is the real
callback hell the real
challenges of asynchronous code and
looking at some new stuff
some libraries but also some new things
in javascript that will help you
make it simple again so pyramids
pyramids of doom do exist
um i've been looking at a lot of code
for sidekiq as kind of research for what
people are doing in terms of their code
and it's out there like if you look on
github some node code has
inline callbacks five levels deep you
know
there's no way you can reason about this
stuff it's just a nightmare uh there's
no way you could test this in a million
years
there's really no need for this kind of
uh callback hell like
for the for most the code that i see it
for there's just no need for it
in the simple cases like something like
this so this is a
just some simple express js handler
we're getting a user we're going to
update their profile we want to check
out you know do they have a profile
already
or are we creating a new one so just all
very simple stuff if we're writing the
synchronously it'll be
super simple if you start just starting
out node and you don't you don't know
any other way you might end up with
something like this
so we're handling errors all over the
place we've got quite a kind of deep
stack of nested callbacks
we don't want to do this for two reasons
first off it's completely untestable and
i personally find that test codes
without test is just not code
i don't really count that as code that's
kind of a hack that's like an experiment
without code i just don't trust it and i
wouldn't really trust someone else's
code i certainly don't trust my own code
if it doesn't have tests
so how do we test this code whether we
know where we'd have to dig
right in so if you have a look at the
two points i've got these comments
saying we can't test this stuff
there's no way of getting in there it's
inside a closure we'd have to test the
whole lot in one go so all of those
callbacks
or nothing so we either have to stub out
every little bit of our code there
or uh we just have to give up and not
test it it's not cool
just don't it's not it's not doable so
we can't do this so we just can't do
this kind of uh
stuff we have to name all our callbacks
and reveal them so we either reveal them
individually in the kind of no objects
just have loads of blobs of functions
just have a name so we can actually get
at them with our tests
or we stick them in objects and then we
can get them a test again
so everything has to have a name all
your callbacks should have a name you
should be able to get at them
and test them individually and that lets
us split up the input output stuff which
is the complicated stuff
the asynchronous bit with the simple
code we have inside our handlers which
say
if i have an error and a user what
happens if i have a no error and a user
something good happens all that kind of
stuff it suddenly becomes easy again as
soon as we do that
reason b javascript already has tools to
avoid most of the simple case
kind of causes of complexity
so the named functions obviously but
secondly the
function not bind so how many views have
used function.bind
cool okay so most of you well function
not bind is a really really nice little
tool that lets you
get a new version of a function that's
kind of partially filled in
so let's say we if we have a look at the
um
save profile method here it has three
bits of context we're kind of going
halfway through a process so it already
has
the user we've already got the user and
we're going to the next bit of the
process we either get an error or
profile
so if we were doing this all in line
we'd obviously just reference the
variables in the closure
but as i said can't do that we can't
test it how can we get around that with
bind
well we can use bind we pass it this
which is the context of
this inside the new bound function and
we pass it some of the variables which
kind of fill it in
and we get back what's called a partial
function which is exactly that it's like
a new version of the function where one
of the arguments has already been set
that's what you get so we've avoided
using closures and therefore the
untestability
just with pure javascript so buying kind
of
fills in the stuff we get this partially
bound function
and we can apply it easily so it's nice
and simple um
it's not ideal if we have a look we've
got our two kind of solutions to this
we've got naming so we can test we've
got bind so we don't have to use
closures
we obviously have to percolate this
context down in our functions
it's a little bit fragile if we need to
change the context we're all doing it by
hand
um so it's okay but we you know we've
won haven't we we've finished callback
hell
not exactly these simple cases that
people in blog posts say are completely
insoluble
definitely have solutions but uh they're
still pay points
so what happens when we have lots and
lots of asynchronous stuff let's say we
have a list of of files we need to apply
some transform to all of them
asynchronously
or in this case we have uh two processes
we want to run in parallel
well bind can't help us there naming is
not going to help us there
we need to have some kind of way of
saying when both of these things are
done
progress okay
javascript doesn't give us any tools
natively to do that we're gonna have to
start writing them ourselves we're gonna
have to start implementing this flow
control
ourself which is not ideal because every
single time we do something
we're gonna have to write some of this
kind of a ad hoc code
with sets so enumerables all collections
of things so
for all the users do this asynchronous
process for all the files do this
asynchronous process
again you can see this is all very ad
hoc code you know i've just got this
like
done counting how many of them we've
finished so far and then finally
it does the callback with the array of
of uh the outputs of this asynchronous
process
so it's a bit of a pain point uh we're
writing code again and again and again
to get around some kind of problem
there's something wrong with our code
that makes us continuously have to write
this ad hoc code to solve it
um well maybe we could just get someone
else to write the code for us
you know we can see these kind of
patterns coming up again and again
someone else must have had this problem
and indeed they have and they came up
with something called async js
woo so hthjs is a nice library for node
all the concepts in it could easily be
applied to any kind of callback scheme
so when i say node i mean
the node callback scheme in that you
have an
error parameter and then result
parameter in your callbacks
um you could change it for other ones
and basically it's all the code you'd
otherwise have to write
if you wanted to solve these kind of
problems so it replaces your ad hoc code
it's a library of code it doesn't do
anything special doesn't require any
crazy language extensions
and it handles all the kind of patterns
you might see so a chain of processes
where
each function's output goes into the
next one exactly the same as compose
with synchronous code it has a kind of a
dual
in asynchronous code so we're water
falling down
the code or we might be talking about
parallel
as i'm saying so when all of these
callbacks have fired give me this
callback and have all the results in it
we might be talking about enumerations
so mapping over files all that kind of
stuff
as i said it relies on this interface
this error result interface
it could rely on another one if you
wanted to rewrite it the kind of concept
is going on is that we can replace the
manual ad hoc code
by using an interface and just writing a
whole library around it so it's not
going to do any good for you for like
browser stuff
unless you do some adapting work now the
problem for me with async js is
it is still an ad hoc solution it's just
someone else has written a bunch of code
using the ad hoc solution it's still a
leaky abstraction
and what i mean by that is if it hasn't
had doesn't have a helper for your
precise
situation you're still going to have to
write the ad hoc code
so in that simple example we had a fetch
a user
fetch that user's profile and then using
both of those bits of information
do something else so to fetch the user
and then fetch that guy's profile
is a is a waterfall it's a chain but
then taking both those bits of
information
is a parallel thing we need both those
and if you look at the
um the signatures for those functions
unfortunately we can't do them both at
once
there's no helper that does both at once
in async so we're gonna have to go back
to some kind of a
you know ad hoc code to sort that
problem out
and this is to me this is a classic
example of a leaking abstraction
we still haven't solved the problem at
its root we're still having to write
more and more and more and more and more
code
and async's quite a big library it's not
just one simple concept it's basically a
bunch of hairy code
covering all the different edge cases
what is the root problem i'm talking
about what is causing all this hairy
code
well i think it's the fact we don't have
values when we use
callbacks so when you call a normal
synchronous function you get something
back
like regardless how long it takes could
take 10 minutes it could be blocking for
10 minutes but you still get something
back
before the next line of code executes
and that means we can do things with
that
value we can you know use if statements
we can full loop over it all that kind
of stuff
but we can't do anything in our programs
with a value that doesn't exist yet
and that's a problem with callbacks it
replaces values with flow control
as in we jump around the program we
don't have a value that we can kind of
use in our programs it just doesn't
exist yet
everything's kind of easy with value so
this is a synchronous version of our
process
you can see it's just kind of you know
programming 101 stuff it's really really
really simple
and that is our process like the
asynchronousness of it
is not inherent if you see what i mean
it's just an implementation detail
it could be this simple if our language
was good enough
can we get values with async is that
possible what is
um there's an abstraction called
promises or futures
um which has been around for a while and
the basic concept is
rather than a callback that kind of
flies over your head and you kind of
don't know where
the value is you gives you an iou
and that's a value you get back straight
away so rather than as i say taking a
call back and kind of jumping somewhere
with the value in a future point
it gives you an iu piece of paper saying
i owe you one user
and then you can do stuff on that value
so just like normal normal code you get
your value straight away
and the basic api is it's later
fulfilled
as in the user has appeared or rejected
as in i couldn't find the user or there
was some error in the process
exactly once and the other idea is it
doesn't matter when that happens
so if it happens immediately
and you attach your your callback later
or you'll call back your request for the
value of the promise
it doesn't make any difference so it
takes time out of the equation
it's a lot more like linking up cells in
a spreadsheet when you're using promises
and then the second really important
idea is that
if you apply a function to a promise
you get a new promise back which is a
promise for the transformed
value inside that promise so they chain
so we have a look over here we've got a
promise for a coming back from our get a
function
and then we use the promise for a and we
say then some callback
and that will return a further promise
for value for b and we can see the
comparison with a
a standard callback interface below
so this is the bit where it gets really
useful so we've got get a
then and we've got a function over a and
we're saying
return get b so that whole chain
this change just like jquery or lots of
other libraries now returns a promise
for b
and we can use that in future bits and
pieces the basic api is just this then
so you can see the direct comparison
we've got the promise for a then
callback and error back
versus the the callback method where we
have
thanks useful uh
cool uh yeah so we and then the callback
version we have the error and then the
the value so there's a very
kind of tight um parallel between those
two apis
so it changed as i say that promises the
core idea one of the two core ideas i
think it promises is that chains
for reasons unknown jquery's api
implementation doesn't chain so it's not
really a good
implementation of promises so i'd avoid
that like the plague um
and yeah they just let make things
really simple again so if we have a
process here where we're trying to
threading through um
so this is from a project i did called
tweedart that was like a
machine learning twitter client and it
needs to get a tweet
and then it needs to format the tweet
and then it needs to run a classifier on
the tweet and you can see that process
kind of gets flattened down
we don't have any real complexity there
and the whole process returns a promise
for the final value you should say we
got the twitter next tweet gives us a
promise for a tweet
then when we get the tweet we put it
through the formatter that's a promise
for a formatted tweet
and then we get a promise for a
classified tweet at the end
and because there's no there's no real
reason we can't have multiple consumers
for one promise it's easy to tag on
operations like logging
whatever else you need you can chuck it
out and everyone can get it
so if we have a look at the earlier
thing where we're having multiple
dependencies
um because we don't worry about time
anymore we can
just get the first thing we can before
we even have it we can pass it into
the process that takes the first thing
and then we can use
some method like all to pass both of
them on to a third process without any
nesting it's just super easy
it's completely uncoupled to time we can
already start reasoning about stuff
that hasn't come back yet whereas with
callbacks we'd have to be doing all this
threading via flow control
a lot more complicated and manual
um and interestingly it works with a lot
less library code
so if we just have promises we don't do
any other code at all we just
implement that two function api the then
thing
we can start doing really interesting
stuff because we can
here we have a map over three files we
return a promise for the contents of the
file each one
and we map over the promises so we now
have the final function here
is a we get a a variable contents that
contains a promise for the contents
and we can return a new promise which is
a promise for the transformation of that
contents without any additional library
code
because it's a value it works with stuff
like maps it works with every other
possible enumeration function you could
think of
it's already there to play with so we
don't need to do anything in particular
we can make it even better with with
libraries but i think it's a much
happier abstraction for that reason and
you'll see throughout the talk from this
point on i think promises
solve that one problem that you can
never get away with if you don't have a
value
which is you can't talk about stuff
until it appears with callbacks whereas
your camera promises
so have we won yet well we seem to be
doing pretty well
but i'd say we still haven't won we
solved one core problem with callbacks
but i reckon there's another one
also two kind of pointers with promises
you need to ensure you catch all the
errors
so when you do the then promise doesn't
have any idea of
if you're finished yet and so it'll just
soak up all the errors in the rejection
handler unless you say
done in most libraries to say like from
this point on just throw the error if
if it's if it's there and it's not being
handled
so do make sure you do that
and you still have to unwrap them so
javascript has all this great stuff like
tries and catches and for loops and
things that we just can't use with
asynchronous values whether they're
promises
or if they're um callbacks we can't use
them generically we have to
unwrap them from their process so they
either have to come into the callback
and we get them out of the callback or
we have to unwrap them from the promise
and then use them so we write a lot of
additional craft where
we're effectively unwrapping the async
value from the asynchronous process
and then putting it into our ifs or our
fours or whatever
it'd be really nice to be able to use
things like tries and catches and ifs
and else just straight on the results of
asynchronous values as if they were
synchronous
that was what a library sorry a language
that was designed for async would look
like
like why make it more complicated than
it already is
and i think this is the kind of
irreducible hell of callbacks
is that we kind of break javascript all
the javascript we know and love we can't
use with this stuff
we have to unwrap and then we can
finally get to it we can't just use it
natively
but but there's a pretty cool
concept called a weight
uh this is some kind of pseudo code um
imagine a language it supports a weight
languages that do sport away are things
like c sharp so we have a trying to
catch and we
we await the result of an asynchronous
callback a couple of times here so we
can say okay if a
equals await the capital a so we've got
some asynchronous stuff going on and
it's just going to stop at that point
nothing's going to happen and then it'll
come back so we're using asynchronous
code you know
asynchronous implementation we can run
loads of async at once we still have the
the performance of async but we get back
a synchronous looking code
which is great because the language is
not as implementation it doesn't matter
if a language looks synchronous as long
as the async io is still going on the
background so we can support lots and
lots
of users and all that kind of good stuff
so could we possibly do this i mean we
can't really do it in in
javascript surely surely this is the end
of javascript do we have to
use some kind of new crazy language that
compiles to javascript or just give up
no javascript has a new trick up a
sleeve coming very soon we had a talk
about es5 today
but now we have es6 we will have soon
hopefully
so there's a concept in es6 called
generators and this will let you do
i'm sure a load of really cool stuff
that no one's even thought of yet but
one of the really exciting stuff it does
is allows you to write code that looks
like synchronous code
so before we um go any further i'm just
going to talk a little bit about
generators
they're in the draft es6 spec uh that's
supposedly going to be finalized
december this year
um unless someone's heard an update from
that uh
it's in the draft so it's kind of if the
spec gets approved it will be in there
and it looks like this so it has a
little star operator next to a function
to say i'm a generator function
or a generator kind of constructor and
it has the yield keyword
now what yield does is at that point it
returns control back to the cooling
whatever's calling the generator so you
can kind of think of it as kind of
intermediate return
and it pauses execution inside that
generator so we won't go on to the next
line of code until the generator is
resumed so we literally pause at that
point
so if you go have a look at this code
here we have a wild true loop
which is never a good signing code you
see a wild tree loop in your code you're
thinking ah this is a bit of a nightmare
but it works fine with generators
because we control when it's resumed
every time it hits that yield inside the
while loop
it's going to return control to the
calling
environment and it's not going to go
around the loop again until we
hit next so it's kind of like we can
pause and play it again
so let's you write things like i don't
know uh things that generate long
sequences of code extremely
of numbers or something extremely nicely
concisely
uh and you can see the api here we call
we
as i said it's a it's a kind of
generator constructor when we call it we
get back a generator we get an instance
of the generator
so we call it first count now we have
our counter it's the generator itself
and then we call dot next on it and then
we get back a kind of tuple thing it's a
it's an object with two keys value and
result
and then we can have a look at the uh
sorry value and done
and we can have a look at the value see
what we've got out and that will be the
thing that's been yielded
so it's kind of like the return keyword
in that respect and we also have a
done and we can check if it's done and
basically if it's done it's fallen off
the bottom of the generator just like
normal
cool so what does it look like um let's
have a look
so here is a thing called three queries
you can see it's relying on some glue
code that we're going to have a look at
in a bit called a weightable
and we've set up three queries a b and c
we set ourselves a result array and then
we're just using the standard
javascript i know not quite the standard
we this is just a gratuitous es6
demonstration it's using the for
of not for in so we can just uh
just go straight over an array without
any indices or anything
very cool feature of es6 so we're going
over the whole array of
our promises and we're just hitting
yield and that's going to block at that
point
we get out the generator and then we'll
come back when the promises
has been fulfilled so you can see that
this is parallel
we've done all the queries we started
off all the queries on the first three
lines
so they're all going in parallel and
then we're going to block on them all
until they're all done and then we're
going to return the result away array
so it's very concise and clear but it's
also very fast
because it's parallel async good
combination
cool now this is this is the point i
have to like oh can i actually explain
this
how does this actually work well proviso
this is
a black box the way you do the the
generator implementation
you can kind of ignore it um or you can
understand it's not very difficult
you can you can either do this with
promises or with callbacks in the same
way if you have an interface for your
callbacks
you can do this with callbacks too i
think generators with promises are a
little bit more powerful for a reason
i'll explain
in a second but let's have a look at how
this works okay so
we this is the q.a sync function so this
is the
thing that given a generator returns
a kind of a weightable one so generators
as i said could be used for loads of
different things
not just this but we're going to use the
generator for this await
style keyword so we get our make
generator function and we return a new
function
that's the kind of decorated one um
now we set up a continuous function that
takes a verb and we're using bind again
so it's lucky i talked about that
we make two versions of the continuum
function one that's going to go
next on the generator and one that's
going to go through on the generator
and the next one just resumes it as
we've seen before
okay so we start off just by calling the
callback which is going to
go into continuer the verb's going to be
next
it's going to ask for the next result of
the generator so it's going to run until
it hits the first yield
and then give us back the promise if we
throw an error at this point then it's
going to return a rejected promise it's
fine
if the result's done we're going to
return the value of that entire
process but the important bit really is
if it's not done
we're going to say cue up that promise
because it's yielding promises every
time that's the whole idea cue up that
promise
and when it's done if it succeeds we hit
call back so we
loop and if it fails we hit error back
so we throw
now throw is really super because
throw i hope i have a try catch example
in here
yeah here we go it's not it's not even
javascript it's a bit unfortunate
um but throw will literally throw an
error from that point inside your
generator so suddenly your asynchronous
processes work with
try and catch which is completely
amazing you can suddenly
granularly put a try and catch around
each one of your async processes that
might fail
again you can use try capture it's
pretty amazing uh
cool and that's it that's all you need
and the sim
the glue code for using it with
callbacks is even shorter
it's amazing and like i say i mean this
is just one use of generators they're
going to be
pretty amazing so having a look at a
dependent process
we can just yield a wait for it to come
back
and then put into b it's just like
synchronous code we get the value back
um parallel processes as i said are
pretty easy we just kick them off we get
the promises from both
and then we can just loop over and block
now the point i was making about
callbacks is
you still can't do it like this with
callbacks because we're still going to
have the same problem
where we don't have the value yet to
reason about um there's nothing in the
machinery that's going to let us give
back something
uh so we're going to have to block on
the callback straight away just one at a
time so you can't do parallel processes
with
um with just callbacks you can with
promises
enumerable is pretty easy just looping
over arrays uh
and obviously this all works with async
as well if you're using the callback
style
sweet so seems like kind of asynchronous
code is a solved problem well the last
thing that we can't do with async and i
don't think we're ever going to be able
to do
is to wrap the async bit of our code
and ignore it from the rest of our code
so we have a synchronous bit of our code
and async
because we can never stop um the
asynchronous code kind of leaking out
we're always going to have to deal with
async code everywhere in our code base
and that's simply because js is always
going to be single threaded and there's
no way
of um having what i call a deep co
routine where we block the whole thread
all the generator does is go back to the
calling environment it doesn't block the
entire interpreter and this is a good
thing
if we had threads we'd have all the kind
of problems with threading that we don't
have with javascript so it's actually
good
this is the kind of level of pain we
should accept in javascript um
we have synchronous looking code it's
pretty easy to
to reason about i think we've won i
think we've won
asynchronous code is kind of easy again
uh that's pretty exciting
so we've got javascript back we can use
ifs we can use else's we can use fours
and tries and catches it's all pretty
easy
um we need to wrap our code with these
kind of glue code things and use
generators
it still leaks the async everywhere in
our code but we're happy with that we
avoid threading hell
which i think on balance is far worse
than um
callback hell cool
so um to sum up
don't inline everything it's terrible
you need to write tests
javascript has the tools to solve the
simple cases and when they fall down we
have our kind of trio of tools we can
use async
it's pretty good it's not a great
abstraction it kind of leaks and when it
leaks we can use
promises promises also solve the whole
time issue
we finally have a value game we can
write code straight away
we can kind of link it all up like a
spreadsheet
and then finally if we want to write
some really nice looking code
we can use generators you can use
generators right now by the way in
chrome canary
and node 0.11 with the harmony flag
and they're coming pretty soon there's
also a tracer compiler that compiles
from es5 to es6
includes generators by some crazy voodoo
um
so you can use it today and and firefox
but is it still the python generators or
yeah i thought it was
sweet okay so firefox soon firefox
currently has an old version of
generators but it will soon have the
best version of generators
thanks a lot cool um that's me
come
you